hey
players it's the josh from the josh
speaks and today's one minute monday
is all about how to tackle life one
mission at a time
far too often we find ourselves adding
to our plate but never taking things off
of it it seems like our to-do list is
growing and growing and every single day
is dedicated to playing catch-up rather
than focusing on what we want to do
think about it do you have clothes to be
washed dishes to be cleaned beds to be
made and websites to be updated when we
look at things
on the macro level it just seems like a
bunch of tasks but if we come from a
different angle
suddenly the unapproachable becomes
approachable focus each day on
contributing to one big task
and one small task by narrowing down
what you're working on you're able to
manage your time more efficiently
so instead of feeling overwhelmed by
hundreds of things can you work on your
big task right now
or your small one whichever one you
don't do you'll get to the other one
later
using this little trick will help you
keep your mind on the prize and slowly
chip down your to-do list until you can
finally see over it
thanks for having me evan and for all
you guys out there don't forget
to believe
hi raquel english here with mermaid
junkie tv are you on evan's newsletter
subscription
if not you should be i read every single
one and you should too
ciao
you